this weekend thousands will fill the
desert south of Las Vegas for them in
400. oh yeah it's a big one but the
off-road race also has plenty of fun on
the street Brian will joining us live
from Fremont Street with mint festivals
begins tomorrow so you've got the big
haulers behind you oh and I see Atomic
Liquors one of our favorites right
good morning
yeah good morning guys we did switch
spots a little bit here while we may be
on the road this race takes place off
the road and I've got Matt here with me
from the mint 400 and we've been talking
this morning there's a lot going on it
kicks off with a parade today on the
strip and then there's a free concert
and tell us about that free concert Matt
uh it's really cool Tim Montana's
playing a free show Thursday night on
third in Fremont right in front of The D
Hotel and he's actually racing with us
so he's going to play a concert and the
next day he's going to hop into a race
car and come race with us wow talk about
a talent from you know the concert to
then racing and what else could people
expect the next few days well it's going
to be an action-packed weekend I mean we
have the off-road Festival tomorrow down
here in Fremont and that's free and open
to the public and then two days of
racing Friday and Saturday out at state
line at Prim and tickets are on sale you
can get that good tickets on the
mint400.com and we have a great VIP area
for the people who want to do our right
that's awesome a lot happening here and
what's the one thing you're looking
forward to this year the big thing
that's catching us or what's new this
year well there's always new things
we're always adding new things so this
year we partnered with formula D and
they're coming out to do drift demos so
that's really cool we also have four
four different bands on the Monster
Energy music stage so there's gonna be a
lot of music out there there's food
there's lots of of beer and and whiskey
and wine we've got everything to have a
good time awesome well thank you for
joining us Matt I'll let you get to work
if you can hear some of the crews are
getting ready behind us getting this
street set up for all the activities
happening with them in 400. back to you
guys